faire la remise de dons en place luiz
demel pose la nouvelle hypothèse de
jacqueline une prothèses faciales en
silicone
elle doit la remplacer tous les trois
ans ce merveilleux
en 2011 elle a perdu son oeil droit
infectés par un champignon microscopique
la première fois j'ai pris louis dans
mes bras je me souvenais pleurer elle
m'a donné mon visage
j'aurais pu vivre de la même manière
c'est clair j'ai repris les activités
presque aussitôt que j'ai eus l'hypthèse
louise à redonner un visage à jacqueline
et à plus de 600 autres personnes depuis
20 ans elle façonne avec minutie des
oreilles des nez des yeux
au fil des ans elle a aussi créé des
orteils des doigts et dessins la partie
la plus difficile à recréer un oeil
parce qu'un et c'est une forme une
oreille
si vraiment fixe mais l'oeil représente
beaucoup
les émotions pilat le résultat est
impressionnant c'est le même expression
dans l'oeil on le voit il brille il est
le même à l'appui les couleurs c'est
extraordinaire le processus est long au
départ un chirurgien près par l'oeil
ensuite la fabrication de la prothèse
ensuite la finition un art bon ancienne
infirmière louise a appris son métier
par compagnonnage parce qu'il n'existe
pas d'école au pays
elle est la seule au québec à posséder
cette expertise
aujourd'hui elle redonne au suivant et
forment sa relève
parce qu'elle prépare sa retraite au
printemps de pouvoir bénéficier de tout
l'enseignement de louis c'est un
privilège louise a dû porter sur ses
épaules très longtemps le fait d'être
seul
on n'est pas immortel ans n'est pas
invincible et puis c'était pour aussi la
pérennité
mais avant de quitter louisa un grand
souhait que son métier soit reconnue par
le ministère de la santé et des services
sociaux son titre d'emploi aux chutes
québec et thérapeute par l'art partout
ailleurs au pays comme dans le monde
le métier des pétainistes et reconnu
c'est une bel accomplissement je me suis
réalisé beaucoup dans ce métier là mais
c'est sûr que de d'obtenir mon titre
victimes
en partant ou à voir que je parte je
serais très très très heureuse le
ministère a reçu trois demandes en 2006
2008 et 2014 pour modifier ce titre
d'emploi il a refusé parce qu'il
n'existe pas de programme de formation
officiellement reconnue au québec et au
canada pour cet emploi aussi parce qu'il
n'ya qu'une personne dans le réseau qui
exercent les tâches des pistes existent
et ce sur une base variable louise
travail portant à temps plein il ne sera
plus la seule bientôt le chute québec
refuse de nous dire s'il fera une autre
demande comme le souhaite louise ici
alexandra duval radio canada québec